العقيد ما رأيك في قدرة الولايات المتحدة على ضرب
إيران دون ضرب داخل
الأراضي الإيرانية كما يقترح آرون
وربما تحقيق توازن يبعث
برسالة دون إخراج الأمور عن
السيطرة أعتقد أنه من الضروري أن
تفعل الولايات المتحدة ذلك جيم وأنت تعرف باسم عون  كنت
أشير إلى هذا، كما تعلم أن هناك
عدة خيارات هنا معظمها
سيئ للغاية أه ولكن الخيار الأفضل من
سلسلة الخيارات السيئة هو
ضرب شيء مهم جدًا
للإيرانيين ولكنه ليس شيئًا مهمًا
ضربات في قلب
النظام أو في جوهر بعض
قدراتهم ولكن سيكون بمثابة
تحذير لهم فشيء مثل
مهاجمة أه أصول بحرية في
الخليج العربي أه شيء من هذا القبيل كان نوعا ما
يصل إلى الخط أه لكن  تعلمون أنهم
يستطيعون فعل ذلك أو يمكنهم الاستمرار في
ضرب الوكلاء سواء في العراق أو
سوريا ولكن إذا كانت هناك يد
مخفية تم الكشف عنها لنفترض أن جهة
الاتصال من تان هي التي ربما
وجهت هذا الهجوم أه فعليهم أن
يفكروا في الذهاب  كل هذا الطريق لإرسال
رسالة إلى الإيرانيين